this evening we're going to take a look
at character categories and I hope it's
going to be fun
I think it will be fun I have I pick six
six particular categories I obviously I
can't do all 14 in one night we will be
falling asleep here but we will talk it
through and what what the examples are
and I picked examples for specific
reasons I'll tell you when we get there
some like for instance some adversary
characters in major motion pictures are
pretty obvious right and therefore I
picked one that isn't obvious so you can
see the other side of it too okay
now then perspective Erik does like the
Greeks doesn't he what is character you
know in a screenplay or a novel and they
are both important because they are very
different and we'll get to that in a
second about 400 BC what's his name Theo
frost Asst Theophrastus was a Greek
philosopher and he sat down and made up
this list it was about you know 70 types
long but made up a list of types of
people based upon predominant
predominant attitudes flatterer
garrulous bore reckless superstitious
and so forth I'm not quite sure why he
did it because he was a philosopher not
a dramatist but it just turned out that
one of his students was named Menander
and Menander as some of you obviously
woops Menander went on to make a career
out of writing somewhere around 100
comedy plays based upon these character
types using the types of people in
exaggerated form to
create comic characters Menander
basically was the first comedy writer
first playwright comedy writer in
history as far as we know and he did
quite well he had a good career at it
but attitude types do not relate to plot
function and what we must concern
ourselves with and obviously as I
eliminate other possibilities here we're
talking about plot function and that is
where we go to the 14 character
categories early on I mean this was
Moliere was doing this you know almost
2,000 years later using the types the
exaggerated types all of which was swell
but the plots were not necessarily
dependent upon those characters feeding
into them okay I just typed in character
categories and googled it and this is
what came back this is contemporary this
is a few months ago round character flat
characters stock character one
dimensional three dimensional but again
this has nothing to do and misses
completely story purpose and that's what
we're looking for the story purpose of
characters because the storytelling
function of a character in film is
critical it's absolutely critical work
even more critical than it is in novels
right so every character present in your
screenplays and scripts other scripts
they have to be there to serve the plot
the story and moving it forward and
there's only two ways that they can
serve a story they either are there to
help or to hinder the progress of the
hero that's it and let me tell you this
is this is why that is true okay and
then we have to back up a bit and I have
I have had lots of students through the
years who come in with
attitudes towards story and character
that they have learned from teachers and
professors of English and of literature
and in other words from novels and the
difference between novels and motion
picture visual storytelling couldn't be
more extreme and pen and separate
absolutely separate first of all here is
how a novel works number one it is
subjective subjective they are it is
always an interior monologue which means
there is a narrator writing it or
talking it and talking to you the reader
that makes it subjective it is the
opinion of one person basically and even
when the story is written in third
person or third person omniscient you
know like the voice of somebody looking
down from heaven upon the scene and
describing everything and then jumping
from inside the head and feelings of one
character to inside the head and
feelings of another character that - is
completely subjective because some God
is narrating it - in writing in novels
you've got sentences in paragraph and
they can own at paragraphs and they can
only focus on one thing at a time
what a sentence describes the sunset and
describes the way the trees are blowing
in the breeze or whatever it is and then
the next single thing gets addressed one
thing at a time so what happens is well
it only works in that the reader
provides everything else from your own
memories your own oh yeah I remember
then you kind of fill in the details and
help create that fictional world of the
novel in your own imagination and that
too is subjective the whole process here
of reading and enjoying a novel and
experiencing that story is subjective
three novels can take side trips they
don't have to be
read in one sitting bacon temple tribe
war and peace you're gonna be having
several sittings to get through it yes
but that means there's less focus on
plot not always but in general it is
looser
it is looser the Pope lot thing is
looser let me see I was just thinking
about Ernest Hemingway book but for Whom
the Bell Tolls anybody read it grand
total of one okay I know it's another
era of another era I was I was a
Hemingway a fan when I was in my teens
you know and I compulsively read them
all kind of stuff but for Whom the Bell
Tolls is a really great book but the
main story is it takes place in
revolutionary Spain in the mid 30s just
before World War two Francisco Franco as
a dictator - had taken over Spain and
the rebels were in the mountains
fighting to return to democracy and
that's the main plot but there is one
character in it by the name of Pilar a
woman by the name of Pilar as I recall
she was she's about 50 years old
I can't remain you know that's the image
that still this objective image that
still stays with me all these years
later right but she's taking all the
risks of all the other people she risks
death every day when they go into battle
and so forth but Hemingway grew so fond
of her that for almost 90 pages he takes
a sidestep and writes her entire story
and her entire backstory and it's
wonderful I mean it's him writing prose
which is wonderful by definition and
then some 80 or 90 pages later he comes
back to the main plot and continues you
cannot do that in visual storytelling
that is a quality only available in
novels in the in literature
you can't do that plot can be looser
because it's not limited to two hours
only and has to be seen in one sitting
describes feelings and thoughts that you
know the narrator goes from inside the
feelings and thoughts of one and
describes them and describes the other
so we can subjectively know people's
emotions okay now here's the movies film
is exactly the opposite visual
storytelling is as utterly objective as
novels are subjective when we go into a
theater and sit down and the movie
begins everybody in that audience sees
exactly the same thing every everybody
there is we don't bring our own
imagination to it we see the exact same
thing everything has been decided the
set the the lighting the costumes the
blocking everything is taken care of and
does not require our imagination to feed
over it and secondly instead of one
thing at a time motion pictures give to
us a deluge of information all at once
hundreds of individual there's motion
and there's color and there's speech and
there's action physical action and it's
all happening at once and that's why
it's such an overwhelming art form it is
the most overwhelming and / you know
personally involving art form so far
that there is in the world because of
this deluge of information no side trips
you got basically you've got
approximately two hours to tell your
story beginning to end and then
everybody goes home it's not done in
small little bites like you would read a
novel over time it has to be complete in
two hours and that means no side trips
none and because it is utterly objective
that means the only way we learn really
are
about character is by what they do
behavior in film is character in novels
that can be describing go inside and you
know this and that is going on inside
you know Sasha you don't you can't do
that I'm not saying that there isn't
dialogue and people can say ouch because
they're feeling pain or something but
for us to know it and to share it it has
to be behavior which can be seen
three-dimensional visual and that is why
when you build a story a visual story
you are providing the plot that will
allow your characters but specifically
your your key character to take this
journey and demonstrate who they are and
demonstrate how they grow and how they
change by the end that is very
completely different really then not
been novels okay
therefore all characters must serve the
ends of in that two hours making that
hero's journey his or her trip through
whatever your story is they must feed
into that and they have to either help
or hinder the hero and simultaneously be
providing conflict visible present tense
conflict so that's how we arrive at the
14 character categories now you saw this
last time here it is again and I just
want to run these past you one more time
these are in the book no these are in
the book don't worry about that but uh
this is the first half of them and
tonight I've got examples of here of
adversary love intra sidekick mentor and
endangered innocent the gate Guardian we
will save it's it's usually more of a
lesser part than the others and we'll
save it for another time and then these
are the other seven and these we will
get to over
as we analyzed the pictures that we're
going to be looking at right although
I'll say off the top my head adversary
agent is extremely important because
most adversaries have helped and that
help the ones who do the bidding of and
take the orders from in one way or the
other the adversary
they are adversary agents and there's
various ramifications of who that can be
but that is the purpose
storytelling purpose they serve and down
here it's not really last on the list in
terms of importance at all I don't know
how it arrived down here but the helper
follower allies of the hero are people
who do the same but for the hero helper
followers there's all kinds of different
lungs Ocean's eleven that's a one hero
movie Danny ocean is the hero he has a
sidekick rusty that's another category
we're going to take a look at and then
he has his team all those other guys the
the terrific you smaller parts but they
are key to the enterprise and they are
all helper follower allies okay beyond
the 14 characters of course you have
atmosphere characters the under-fives or
the extras they don't really have a
category I haven't given them a category
here because they do not serve a direct
plot storytelling function what they are
saying it crassly I suppose are props
they are there to make the world if
they're there for verisimilitude to make
the world this fictional world for this
particular story feel real and sometimes
they have a few lines you know the the
sassy waitress who okay you know has a
quick quick cute quip and drops the bill
and we never see her again she has no
story function it's just mail you just
to give it depth and they don't advance
the plot and something else that's
useful about having the character
categories is once you assign a role to
one of your characters and pick them out
of because all of these can provide
subplots all of them once you pick a
particular individual and you paint them
and create them and make them
three-dimensional and once they are in a
category they have to stay in that
category you can't change categories
okay when it happens and I've seen it
happen a few times and it just destroys
movies what's it called the deep end
anybody seen the deep end Tilda Swinton
I think stars in well that alone tells
you something it starts out very
interesting and it's about Tilda Swinton
who whose son who is you know late teens
and applying to college and something
happens and and then all of a sudden it
looks like it's going to ruin his entire
life and there's bad guys and gangsters
trying to blackmail mom and she's
running around trying to fix it and set
it all right but a very strange thing
happens at the midpoint of that movie
his mom just kind of gives up and Falls
in a frump and one of the adversary
agent characters who works for the bad
guy if the midpoint decides to take up
the flag of hero and all of a sudden the
mantle of hero changes from her to
someone else and he is the one who goes
forward and resolves the story and it
doesn't work it eliminates the emotional
connection we have with the characters
it's changing horses midstream and
psychologically for your audience
it just doesn't work we've talked about
the the nine hero sympathy qualities
that's the list this is also in the book
I have put stars there by five of them
because I believe at a minimum every
hero he or he or she
needs to have at least these five
qualities one or two more wouldn't hurt
but they need to have these you this
allows your audience in it allows them
to identify with at least temporarily
and they don't have to be you know just
somebody pure and good we don't much
like pure and good people all that much
they're not very interesting but they
have facets and qualities but one of
those qualities is we have to be able to
like them up to a certain degree and
that goes for all kinds of heroes and
there are a number of different kinds of
heroes all heroes must be at the very
least empathetic and I just put on you
know five different kinds of heroes here
to catch some categories for which this
remains true just to prove the point
anti-heroes a lot of people ask me about
that but Eric Eric this is an antihero
they can't be they can't be sympathetic
well they need to be if it's going to
work remember Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo Lisbeth has anybody seen girl
okay okay
starting to worry there oh yes good good
but Lisbeth is this dark self-contained
she lives in her isolated emotional
bubble because she has been hurt so much
since childhood she is a profoundly
wounded person but she still has six out
of nine of the sympathy characters her
characteristics um tragic hero Scarface
Tony Montana a formal tragedy that's
King Lear that's Macbeth that is a
contemporary that's Scarface and these
are otherwise admirable heroes who have
one fatal flaw within them that they
cannot correct the character growth is
not possible for this person and that
becomes the admonishment
tail of we know that they will be
destroyed and they will be dead by the
end of the movie that it kind of said is
kind of sad because we know what they
could have been too if they had had that
one thing fixed within themselves the
tragic hero Tony Montana in Scarface
tragic hero out of the nine sympathy
tools he has eight of them and it works
quite well catalyst hero have any of you
seen an old movie called the in the heat
of the night good
a couple anyway it's a terrific movie if
you ever want to spend a nostalgia night
Sidney Poitier plays Virgil Tibbs
actually the part that that that year I
think it was uh that was the movie in
the heat of the night that took Best
Picture
I think he did I think he did right
right right
no no there were there were some before
yeah yeah right right although I think
he won maybe that came later lilies of
the field I think he did yeah anyway
history he is a highly skilled murder
investigator for the police homicide
detective from New York very
sophisticated very good at what he does
he's in the deep south for some reason
and he ends up in jail he gets arrested
for something of course that he didn't
do all of which is outrageous
and he is very blustery and terrific
about you know and you can see Sidney
Poitier playing at history they called
me mr. Tibbs and that became the movie
that followed this one when he became
such a popular character I think they
made two or three more movies with him
as the lead and then there is the
redneck cracker small-town Deep South
sheriff right and that was played
Steiger rod stay stikers you have great
character actor and of course you know
he's his cracker as they get and so
naturally you've got this wonderful
personal conflict between these two
people but the one who does the growing
and character growth is the sheriff and
not the the hero not Virgil tipped and
that's catalyst hero that there are
those kinds of heroes who do not
personally change but bring about change
in others trickster hero Axel Foley
remember Eddie Murphy in Beverly Hills
Cop remember that's the old series and
he is the trickster Harry hero is is
it's funny energetic and always sticking
it to the man you know how to use old
terms and very snide and playful and
jester esque with authority
that's the trickster hero and this isn't
in a number of movies like that of with
that character in them but they too need
to be sympathetic and then the mentally
challenged hero that's a whole sub-genre
too
that's not too hard because before
because of their disadvantages going in
they we're automatically sympathetic for
them Forrest Gump
I am Sam dumb and dumber those kind of
you know the mentally challenged
characters are natural we are naturally
affectionate toward them but there's
other things you can't let it you know
you have to keep it keep it alive and
you have to be careful - they have to be
sympathetic as well all just to prove
that the sympathy requirements remain
the same and you need to pay attention
to it okay pop quiz
everybody got to take out a piece of
paper no no no
sorry rotten joke rotten joke
but I do have a question for you for the
pop quiz take a look at this list you'll
get out of your way take of this look
look at this 7:57 titles of pictures
what to think if you've seen two or
three of them
has anybody seen two or three of them
okay okay you guys then what to or
through are two things in all up do all
of these films have in common but
anything pop out at you yes they're I
believe they are all one hero movies yes
but what we're looking for is this they
all have despicably unsympathetic heroes
and all of them bombed at the box office
even even Waterworld that cost over 200
million and at the time that was a lot
of money not anymore but yes these these
are your case examples of when they did
not pay attention to keeping the hero
sympathetic okay just trying to prove
the points okay
now we're going to get into the
character types here first of all we're
going to start with an adversary
adversary is the primary opposition for
the hero right and it's one person
appears unbeatable for you no good hunk
of the movie usually throughout
throughout act two they can wear a mask
of friendship they can be a wolf in
sheep's clothing for a while and then
that comes off and they are revealed who
they truly are but they have not changed
categories they were simply disguised
for a while do you remember the fugitive
again this goes back a few decades but I
was Harrison Ford in his heyday when he
you know an a-list movie star and he is
Richard Kimble on the run he was been
convicted and condemned condemned to die
for his wife's murder which of course is
tearing him apart because he really
loved her a lot but he has a friend that
he had when he was still a doctor and
respected and all that he has a friend
and when he escapes and goes back home
to try to find you know that the
one-armed man and all that who who they
thought was the real killer this is his
friend who he helps him out a little
slips him you know whatever cash he's
got in his pocket you can't give him a
cat you know we can't go to a bank he
needs help and this character that this
other doctor helps Kimball and and
speaks well of him and so forth but what
we find out at the end of Act two is the
helpful friend doctor that's the
adversary who set him up he is he's it
he's the bad guy and then in Act three
it's all about the resolution between
the two of them fight to the death kind
of thing so it can they can wear a mask
of friendship but that not is not the
case they are not always a bad person
and you know that and I'm sure you sure
you've seen and can think of a whole
bunch of adversary characters they're
not bad people they just happened to
because of circumstance with the nature
of the story they come into opposition
with your hero and that can work
extremely well sometimes and remember of
course the adversary must be one person
not an idea not a group it has to be one
person or a personification of one
person by that I mean jaws or one of
those the shark is the adversary there
there's another guy who's messing thing
as an independent troublemaker and
that's the mayor of the town but it's
the shark who is the director adversary
but it's not just a shark
it's a super shark it is the smartest
most devious most bold and vicious and
and seeking of revenge
a shark seeking revenge this is what I
mean by when when such a creature an
animal becomes your adversary they
become more like a person they are
personified it seems some we're gonna
take a look at something I am Legend the
top zombie it's the same thing it is the
sentient zombie who becomes the
adversary because he can think and plan
and hate and he's the only zombie who
can do that that kind of thing ok here
are some examples some classic examples
of adversaries oh heavens who will ever
forget Jamie Gumb is that how you
pronounce his name down here on the
right the nightmares that character gave
to lots and lots of people and certainly
lots and lots of kids he played it you
know the actor who played it it was
written so strong and and and drippy
with menace and then it was played to
the hilt by the actor the poor actor you
know for some a couple of years after
this he couldn't get any more work
because everybody took a look at him and
said oh that's Jamie Gumb it was so
typecast the poor guy he was too good
yeah but eventually you know now he
works all the time yeah he plays a lot
of cop parts oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah yeah oh he's a great actor
yes ok that's but this is clean and
clear I mean this is the bad guy the
crazed killer ok sergeant Foley in an
officer and a gentleman that's up up
there that was Lou Gossett jr. and he
got an Academy Award
I think Best Actor Best Supporting
supporting Best Supporting Actor
he's the drill sergeant and he's not a
bad man he's a very good man with a very
diff
job he is a drill sergeant whose job it
is in these new candidates for flight
school these are all the people who want
to become jet fighter pilots right and
it's his job to weed out the ones who
just might get themselves or somebody
else killed and he the ones who don't
aren't willing to defend and risk
themselves to support and defend their
their fellow fighter pilots and and he
puts a lot of pressure on him to see who
cracks and there are several who crack
and one of them who almost cracks of
course is the hero Richard Gere so he's
not a bad man but oh what a challenge
and what an adversary he presents to be
to the Richard Gere character Miranda
Priestly and The Devil Wears Prada ooh a
woman who just relishes in crushing
people for the pure power of it it's
it's marvelously written and marvelously
play Karen Crowder
that's the character's name from Michael
Clayton how many of you have seen
Michael Clayton mmm that you got to put
on the list Michael Clayton I at the
risk perhaps of getting too personal
that's one of my favorite films Michael
Clayton and that year and I was only on
Oh seven eight years ago I was beside
myself furious that it was overlooked
for the Oscars because there was so much
going on there it was a really terrific
film and her as the adversary you just
got to see this you got to see this
she's an executive you know a woman
trying to climb her way up in the
executive jungle and her interpretation
of how that is done is you do anything
necessary up to and including murder
it's not like she's comfortable with it
but she does it and she is the adversary
it's great it's a wonderful movie agent
Parcher in a beautiful mind this is the
beautiful man I used to try to do that
in this class but it's too long and it's
too complicated and goes you know this
many things to talk about so it really
doesn't work for our purposes but a
beautiful mind is the story of a man
John Nash a genius physicist and he goes
insane he I forget the nature of the
insanity but he yes he has
hallucinations he talks to people who
aren't there I mean his whole career was
destroyed by I mean what can you do you
go insane they don't employ insane
people as professors and scientists but
that could have been done whereas I mean
what does that mean it means that John
Nash is his own worst enemy he is being
destroyed from within that means he's
his own nemesis however it wasn't done
that way when it was turned into a movie
the nemesis the adversary has to be one
person a real person and so Agent
Parcher came onto the scene and was
invented agent Parcher is his strongest
fantasy although he doesn't know it's a
fantasy for you know two-thirds of of
Act two but it's his invention and
projection of a person who has control
of him and that way okay agent Parcher
is the personification the one person
adversary that fills in for him being at
war with himself because Wars you know
battles where people are their own worst
enemy as a rule they do not work we can
talk about that later if you like I got
another example there but Agent Parcher
and Amy done in gone girl okay there's
some great examples now then here's
here's my first example for you for
adversary here's the reason I picked
this one sideways how many of you have
seen sideways
oh good good good most most of you and
it's worth it's worth putting down on
your lists sideways was an independent
small movie outside of the Hollywood
mainstream truly I I checked and I
believe it was made for around six
million dollars total budget its total
gross in its in national theatrical
release was a hundred million dollars
and that's in its first theatrical
release yes that I would say against the
six million it cost to make it did very
well indeed so of course I got it broke
it down and it is the paradigm it worked
because it is the paradigm writ small as
opposed to the big-budget movies where
it's writ large but that is the way it
is structured beginning to end and one
of the things that's unusual about it is
that the adversary most people say Jack
is you know his friend his lothario
friend who keeps getting in more and
more trouble every single day that that
miles the hero had then has to get him
out of that he that he's the adversary
he is not he is Jack in this for those
who have seen it and may see it soon
Jack is a comedic sidekick character and
the adversary is Miles ex-wife Victoria
he is obsessed with and crushed with
depression over they got divorced about
a year ago he lost his wife Victoria we
find out eventually that it was his own
fault but you know it's not her fault
she didn't just dump him he crossed the
line he had an affair
etc old story but she is not physically
present in most of the movie she is
present in two locations this scene
which is very early in
in the second act and then she shows up
and that even that she's not physically
present we only hear her voice on the
telephone and then she shows up in the
obligatory scene remember the the
adversary has to be one person or
personification because of the
obligatory scene that's where they have
to show up in the flesh so that the hero
and the adversary can go for all the
marbles and that's where she shows up
which again is proof that she's the
adversary but it's done so uniquely and
so simply I just I just I really
cherished this adversary is not
physically present the hero's ex-wife
Victoria okay
let's see if I can lay this out for you
quickly I got to do this like that okay
the setup for does a few of you who have
not seen it and the setup is that Myles
has taken Jack his his good buddy on a
bachelor-party trip through wine country
in one week Jack will get married and
Myles is an on a file and that's why
he's taken him to wine country and
showing him around he's proud to show
him how much he knows about wines but
unfortunately Jack has always been a
compulsive chaser of women any woman who
was in the room he it's like it and it
is it's a compulsion and he admits that
later on he says you don't know the
nature of my problem and it's true it's
for him a real problem but that gets him
into all kinds of trouble which means it
pulls miles into all kinds of trouble
okay
Jack recently told miles just Mac a few
hours before this scene but jack told
miles that his ex-wife Victoria just
remarried miles didn't know that
obviously because it wasn't invited to
her wedding and that for miles in this
little movie that is stunning surprise
one because he freaks out
and he's very childish in his response
and he runs back to the car he's just
talking he's waxing loquacious about the
memories of when he came to this
beautiful spot where he'd taken Jack
under this tree and we had a picnic here
and we drank wine and made love and and
then Jack breaks it to him he says look
I was looking for an opportunity when we
were alone to tell you this but Victoria
just remarried and and miles comes
unglued grabs a bottle of wine runs off
into the vineyard as Jack is chasing
after him trying to stop him and he's
slugging back this is the beginning of
act 2
there are remember what we said about
act 2 act 2 well act 1 that fades into
Act two is the adolescence the character
growth in the character growth pattern
it's the adolescence of the hero and at
the beginning of act 2 miles is quite an
adolescent and very childish in his in
his moods and and in his depression and
that's and that it's laid out for us at
the beginning of act 2 this is the
nature of what must change within him in
the character growth arc right so jack
has just set up this blind double date
because he met Stephanie the lady is
sitting beside there in that other
picture and he's coming on full bore for
Stephanie unfortunately he doesn't tell
Stephanie that he's going to get married
in about five days just a little
oversight there and of course that
weighs on miles too because miles has a
better
moral compass than than Jack does about
these things and it's troubling him but
you know he can't blow it up either jack
has set up a blind double date with
Stephanie who got a friend of hers to
come
so basically Maya is miles miles date
for the night but he is ignoring her
completely because he's getting
and he's being depressed miles is lost
in the past all and this kept getting
repeated and even in in act one even his
mother says it he stops off for a scene
with his mother he's you know stealing
borrowing money or something like that
and my mother says oh you should go back
with Victoria you two are perfect for
each other
she is echoing the truth of his
suffering he has always felt that they
would get back together again
and that's his greatest wish and I love
double-entendre titles and that's part
of a double entendre of the title of the
movie which is sideways sideways number
one of course means drunk
it's another you know another term for
tipsy because people move sideways
rather than straight ahead they lose
balance but sideways is also the way
that miles is living his life he can't
go ahead he's stuck he's focused
completely on the past he wants to step
back into the past get that relationship
again and he cannot think about moving
forward and that's why at the moment he
is not communicating very well with the
lovely lady Maya at all miles has lost
in the pan past longing to go home to
Vicki
he can't even and again as a repetition
he can't even see this terrific woman
Maya right beside him Jack doesn't want
a drunk miles to ruin Jack's own chances
of sleeping with Stephanie jack is yes a
narcissist and he's just worried about
his own goals and concerns but he's
sweet and he's funny and he is he has
told miles do not drink and dial he told
him I just outside he's been shaken
amidst you cannot drink and dial I don't
want you spoiling this date so of course
miles drinks a lot drinks a lot of wine
until it gets good and blasted and he
goes to dial stag staggers on back to
the payphone at the back of the
restaurant and the dialing of course is
to Vic
aurilla and so there is a scene here
early in the second act where the power
of the adversary is demonstrated just
here it's only on the telephone she is
not physically present okay Victoria
answers the phone and he's lighthearted
and he tries to be you know upbeat about
it Oh Jack just told me and I called to
say congratulations on your wedding you
know and it's all of course and
it slips into Jack's being sarcastic and
snide and then crashing pretty much
crashing emotionally then he crumbles
and says it again and out loud I just
always felt someday we'd get back
together again
and that's become harder now since she's
gotten remarried and the adversary still
dominates every corner of his life she
has the power here you see how that is
she is more powerful than he she they
divorced she is moving on in life he
can't he's stuck because of his
immaturity and she says miles don't call
me when you're drunk
well didn't help and he kind of weaves
on back to the table miles still is
stuck drifting sideways and more than
anything he still wants to go home to
Victoria and Jack has just ticked off at
him because he's starting to spoil his
odds with Stephanie that's that's Jack's
fist over the top of the wine bottle
cutting him off Myles must learn what
true adult unselfish love is it's a
really very nice very very well drawn
character growth arc he does grow up by
the end okay so now we jump to act 3 and
the one other scene the obligatory scene
in which the adversary appears at great
personal risk Myles has gotten Jack home
just in time to be married and the big
wedding and stuff right and as you can
see in the picture
with the bandage jackers had his nose
broken for those of you who haven't seen
the way he gets his nose broken is when
Stephanie finally finds out that in 24
hours he's going to get married to
somebody else and she whacks him really
hard and breaks his nose okay but miles
is the hero and miles has grown in the
second half of the second act because
Jack gets himself into such deep trouble
and it's pretty pretty outrageous and it
is a hilarious comedy and it's it works
it all works it's awfully well written
but he has made sacrifices and take
taken great personal risks to get miles
back and get him married he has matured
and so he must face the obligatory scene
and here comes Victoria Victoria comes
up to him and introduces her new husband
and rather than the childish reaction
that he got at the beginning of act 2
he's hurt yes he's wounded he's just you
know awful things emotionally are going
on inside of this guy but the new
husband can is is respectful he offers a
handshake is glad to meet him and all
that and then Ken makes himself scarce
just I'll give you guys a minute and
I'll go get the car you know he's a
class act
really this guy miles discovers Ken is
actually a decent guy miles is suffering
yes but he deals with it by also
offering respect in return so they chat
a little bit more he's no longer
behaving like a child
like he was several times earlier and
that's a good thing and miles says well
let's go to the reception and toast to
your wedding
only this time he almost means it and
Victoria says oh she's not going to the
reception she's given up drinking and
that's kind of strange
two miles because they were wine
drinkers and they shared that passion
when they were together
and Ken comes up and she says I need a
minute more and this all sets up for
what's coming you know those of you who
have seen it then the final Tet I mean
she's sweet about it she is taken the
time to make sure he knows in advance
this is an honorable thing for her to be
doing and the final test and the final
blow she says as gently as she can I'm
pregnant for a guy like miles that is
truly the hardest kicking the vitals he
could possibly receive and Victorian can
head off to their future lives together
and miles now knows there's absolutely
no road back that's it her life is
settled and set in another way and he is
not part of it that's never going to
happen he must love her enough to
finally let her go and then there's this
lovely little kind of quasi Daniel Moss
scene where that is his victory at last
he closes the door on the past and he
throws himself a growing up party he
opens his best and most expensive
outrageously expensive bottle of wine
which he was always saving for a very
very special occasion well now he opens
it alone in a burger joint to toast to
the salt and a solitary farewell toast
to Victoria and the past and to a hope
for a new start in the future for
himself okay I got a bit far afield
there because it's a small movie and
small movies are more about
interpersonal things then than the
larger movies and in order to understand
the adversary and the power she has over
this hero you need to know some of this
stuff but this is an extra for this
story and this hero this is an
extraordinarily successful adversary
character she's in two scenes in the
whole movie that's another way of doing
it
okay and these are the requirements
primary opposition for the hero yes
appears unbeatable for a long long time
she sure peers unbeatable and and she's
going to take him down a very bad
emotional trail can wear the mask of
friendship not relevant not always a bad
person she's not she's a true sweetheart
must be a person and so she is so you
can see some of these are fulfilled in
this particular adversary and some of
them are not
the love interest now this is outside of
hero and adversary I believe the login'
love interest character is the most
fascinating of the rest of the character
categories because it's so replete with
emotion and a way to explore the nature
of the hero what is right with them and
what is hurting them and what is wrong
with them to the love interest creates a
subplot or a main plot and drive story
change and humanizes the hero there's
you know through these through intimate
emotions but it's about mate bonding
with a love interest character that's
what it is and there is a way to tell I
think this is important to know because
a lot of people get confused about love
interest characters whether they're Co
heroes or or you know what is their
place in the story there is a way to
know whether a love interest character
is a subplot
or the main plot and it's this if you
took a love interest character and that
relationship out of the movie would you
still have a story that's how you do it
and sometimes we're going to see yeah
when I have some examples here lined up
you'll see what I mean
but that's important to know Drive story
change works alternate leaf for and
against the hero remember every
character category isn't only about
helping the hero there has to be
challenge and there has to be conflict
too for it to work the love interest
character works alternately for and
against the hero and the issue of a love
interest character with the hero who are
here whoever he or she is the love
interest character adds sexual tension
and a sexual conflict going on under the
surface of things
because that plot is about in fact mate
bonding which is in fact about sexual
conquests now I'm stating it bluntly to
make the point I mean there's a lot of
wiggle room there and using this plot or
subplot you can do it
from the very very gentle and and and
hardly hinting at sexuality at all to
the incredibly steamy and everything
everything in between and that of course
depends on you and it depends on the
story you're trying to write you get
your choice but the thing is it is there
and once you have sexual tension between
people it is a universal thing every
nation every language humanity gets what
that is I mean would you we are we are
sensual creatures and therefore you are
offering up emotion that is
international in scope and you can use
that for character growth purposes for
challenges of personality and how people
must grow and all that kind of stuff
it is you it is the well of what you
want screenwriting and visual
storytelling to be which is the pursuit
of emotion it's just it's amazing it
works very well and it also pushes the
hero into character growth ah and yes
people sometimes get this wrong if a
couple is married at the beginning of
the of the of the film above your story
and with some ups and downs whatever you
know but they stay married and they are
reasonably happy together all the way
through the movie into the end that is
not a love interest character it has to
be about this back and forth back and
forth opposing and and then helping and
opening
a couple of examples of that yeah there
are two Apollo movies that have come out
actually three lately but the two that
I'm thinking of our Apollo 13 which goes
back a ways and the the one the latest
one which was overlooked by everybody
which is really tragic because I thought
it was really I've seen it three times
now and it's just riveting in its first
man it was the true rendition of the
true story of both what's his name the
first Armstrong Neil Armstrong but Neil
Armstrong is married and in Apollo 13
Tom Hanks is married to and the married
spouse at home becomes that category of
character that they turn into is the
endangered innocent not a love interest
they become the goal of those two
astronauts they are going through all of
this and all they want to do you know
for all the been you know the problems
that come up and the possibilities of
dying they come up they want to surmount
all that so that they can get back to
earth and save that endangered innocent
from the metaphorical death that she
would also be experiencing if he were to
die in space that is endangered innocent
plot and that is not a love interest
plot okay here's some example
Neytiri where is she oh wait a minute
here she is in in Avatar
Oh again what a what a wonderful
relationship in that picture and this I
ask you she's also doing a whole lot of
mentor duties again but with overlaid
with sexual tension because that's key
to that relationship it just is and
elevates it if you take a net-net eerie
out of
avatar do you still have a movie yeah
you do which means
Neytiri is a love interest subplot it is
not the main plot although she you know
it she's there and it's big and it's
important in all that stuff but all the
same it is a subplot it is not the
primary goal right officer rhoads in
bridesmaids that's easier to see and to
be able to say you know if you took him
out of it could you still have a movie
yes you could
that's a subplot Lisa McDowell in coming
to America if you removed her from
coming to America would you still have a
movie you sure yeah yeah no yeah that's
it this is not fair I'm going back too
far here I'm going back too far you
would not because she is the heroes got
the eddie murphy the prince she is his
goal he goes to America to find a woman
that he can fall in love with and marry
and not have to marry the the woman that
he knows nothing about and really
doesn't care about back home that the
king his father has chosen for him she
is the goal therefore she is a love
interest character who also provides
there's a double role here we won't talk
about it tonight but the love interest
who is the main goal also is plays
adversary they are each other's
adversary and love interests
simultaneously that's why it works
differently and we'll talk about that
another time
Alicia Nash in a beautiful mind if you
take her out what yes it would be
crushingly less interesting and very
diminished but yes you could you could
remove her and you would still have the
man struggling to come back from madness
and making it yes so that is
when one of the character categories
gets played by a movie star and it is
big I mean it takes a lot of screen time
and it's really important to things but
it is still a subplot in its way that is
called a charismatic whatever a
charismatic mentor or a charismatic love
interest they get a lot of screen time
but at their core they are still feeling
filling the functions of these sub
categories
Georgia Coors June Carter how about June
Carter and Johnny Cash if you took June
Carter out of there would there still be
a movie what does he want
throughout he wants Jude Carter even
more than he wants to be famous as a
singer he wants her yeah she is
the love interest adversary for that
film and so forth okay you get the idea
now then this example I've chosen for a
love interest character this is Carol
the waitress in as good as it gets this
one had me stumped for a while when I
first sat down to analyze it I thought
it was a three hero movie and then I
went through it once and I said no that
doesn't work and I took a harder look at
it this is a one hero movie Melvin Udall
is the hero because it is Melvin who
wants Carol she never until you know at
certain points toward the end expresses
really any romantic interest in this
poor man who is trapped in being a jerk
you know because of the nature of how he
defends himself against all emotion but
the beauty of the profession that has
been assigned to him which is a very
successful romance novel writer I mean
it's just it's perfect you know that is
the true him screaming to get out you
know that kind of thing it's yeah I
think it's a wonderful wonderful story
and wonderfully written but okay I mean
at this point and this is as part of a
midpoint sequence
Carol her son I believe it's asthma he's
got asthma really bad the kind that
under certain conditions the kid could
die from and he had a really bad attack
and she got all panicked and she's a
waitress who waits on on Melvin every
morning and how many of you have seen
this okay most okay cool
good then you get it and then after a
heat Belvin sends a top-flight
top-dollar doctor to her apartment to to
see the boy and yes and he writes
prescriptions and he's telling her you
know it's gonna be okay we're gonna
bring him back and he knows how to do it
and she's been getting you know crap
advice from these you know bad cheap
programs healthy health care programs
that she's had Carol couldn't afford the
doctor for her sick son so Melvin got
her a very high-end one and in the
middle of the night she's got up she
sleeps on the couch and she pulled on
her jeans she has to tell
Melvin something she is burning with the
need to tell Mel than something and she
runs out to get to his place in the
night in the middle of the night that's
how urgent this is for her
and that's telling us something right
there well it happens to be raining that
night and she also gets soaked so she's
dripping soaking wet by the time she
gets to Melvin's apartment building and
of course Melvin is very well off and
the apartment is very upscale so here
she is and she's coming up to his front
door this is a comedy this is a romantic
comedy and this whole thing is setting
it up this way especially what she's
going to be telling him be that she has
to tell him face by face that this the
rain is accentuating a sensuality in her
that she is about to deny and it's
perfect as a juxtaposition so
she knocks it's me and Melvin lives
alone self created isolation no one can
stand him early on I guess it's the it's
the next-door neighbour Simon Says to
home who says to Melvin you are a horror
of a human being I mean that's the
general attitude that he has created out
there in the world and then he hears my
goodness it's Carol the waitress
he yes he wants her to wait on him every
day when he goes for breakfast because
she's the only one who will wait on him
you know cuz she can give guff as good
as she gets it from this guy but he has
stronger feelings I mean he's of an age
he's desperate he's got a break out of
his prison and he knows that and he's
drawn to her and one of the reasons
Melvin is sympathetic is we like her too
I mean she's a genuine human being she's
a terrific lady and you can tell by you
know caring for her son you know and she
he's making a good choice here and
therefore we're kind of rooting for him
in strange ways okay but because of his
OCD he has insufferable all he is
insufferable always cracking wise with
sharp put-downs for everyone and she
says I'm sorry about the hour but I must
speak with you she hasn't opened the
door yet and now he opens the door
Melvin so opens the door and immediately
averts his eyes embarrassed at seeing
her t-shirt he was not expecting this
because for him you know the sensuality
there is a it's funny it can end the day
the dial the scene is being played and
what's going on between them but what is
being done here by the writers and by
the director is they are playing the
element of sensuality and sexuality and
mate bonding conquest that is what they
are playing here romantic comedies and
romances all have to have something
insurmountable between the two
lovers insurmountable and that's what
the story is about how they finally get
together in this case what is
insurmountable is Melvin's personality
okay and he's his eyes you know averts
are his eyes and so forth just glancing
at the t-shirt and she finally catches
up with it I mean she's cold she's wet
she wasn't thinking about that
boobs Carroll realizes the physical
picture she is unwittingly presenting
Melvin can't takes take his eyes from
wandering wandering a bit but he also
looks down and sees that she's sopping
wet
you know she's dripping all over the
floor all over the the hallway for a guy
like Melvin you know he can't step on a
crack let alone stand watch somebody
standing there dripping all over
everything
Carol waits for Melvin to be polite and
offer her a bloody towel so he's
flummoxed at this point and so he's
gonna and he goes inside and he doesn't
know quite to do what quite to say and
he Melvin hates thank-yous again it's
part of his no emotion he fights the
emotion at every turn
thank you contain emotion and he always
avoids revealing emotion and that's his
sarcastic nasty wit that's another way
he avoids emotion but he says if you've
come to thank me don't know I put it in
a note he doesn't want any emotion
expressed face-to-face even just in the
thank you so he gets her a towel there's
another funny bit in there we won't go
there
and Carol just has to ask why did you do
this for Spencer that's her son and
Melvin said I wanted you to come back to
the restaurant and wait on me and she
says do you have any idea how odd that
sounds but it's pure Melvin too and we
know that so he blurts it so what have
you come to tell me what is this
and there is one of the more charming
elongated deathly silences between two
people now the awkward silence lingers
has come all this way and this cold in
the wet and she's trying to find the
words to say what she came to say and
it's not coming she really struggles
with it and on until she can finally
blurt it out all at once push it out and
say I will never sleep with you never
that's what woke her up in the middle of
the night and drove her through the rain
she was terrified worried that this is
why he did this and in truth that had
something to do with it we're about to
see that here too
but also again a relative to the sexual
tension okay if that's her a message
that coulda waited until you know next
morning at the at the cafe why this
absolute burning urgency you know
there's something else going on there
all of Melvin's defenses go up and he
resorts to his self protective cynical
sharp tongue because deep down that was
what he was hoping or thinking well we
don't open for the no-sex O's until 9:00
a.m. and again yeah that's that's pure
Melvin right and again he's just being
defensive and obnoxious and that's how
he gets defensive and she's turns to go
and she mumbles I really mean it and he
blurts will you be at the restaurant to
wait on me tomorrow that's a very
strange thing to say and to go through
all of this for that and she says yes
and she goes there's that that's the
scene and next this comes right next and
this only is a few seconds long we cut
to a close-up of his clock and then his
slippers while he's in bed now sleeping
and mumbling to himself habits
half-asleep never she says never and
then he gets up and he puts on his
slippers and what is happening here is
perfect for a midpoint sequence perfect
the second step of character growth
which usually takes place in hero goal
sequence 12 is when the hero undertakes
a physical action some sort of
metaphoric physical action to overcome
what is stopping them and clogging them
emotionally inside and that is exactly
what Melvin does a man who hates all
pills gets up to take his first anti
obsessive-compulsive disorder pill ever
that is a huge thing for Melvin so
alright the love interest as Carol and
at the midpoint we understand you know
the kind of wacky rare and wacky nature
of that relationship creates a subplot
or main plot absolutely drive story
change and humanizes the hero you bet
works alternately for and against the
hero
yes throughout and in other ways she is
doing that adds sexual tension and a
sexual conquest conflict remember that
can be just a small tone a mood it's not
you know nothing blatant or flagrant
necessarily and pushes the hero into
character growth he just took the pill
yes all of that is true of this
character I think it's a very unusual
love interest relationship with the hero
when you see the whole thing I think it
works marvelously okay sidekick that's
that's the Prince Eddie Murphy and then
semi I think semi was the name of his
his loyal sidekick right a sidekick is
not as skilled as the hero but has
certain skills to offer remains complete
loyal as semi does the sidekick is
always loyal does not die unless it's a
formal tragedy yeah then like King Lear
and the fool yeah
provides counsel and conflict yes often
same-sex but not always there are some
very interesting relationships sidekick
relationships that are opposite sex
relationships and can echo a hero's
romance with a comedic one now then here
are some successful sidekicks Dory in
Finding Nemo did see Dory the forgetful
one she is a classic classic sidekick
rusty Ryan in Ocean's eleven also a
classic it's against sometimes casting
throws you off because he's a star
playing the part but it's still the role
and function in the story is that's a
sidekick Ellie burr in insomnia how many
of you have seen insomnia a few okay
yeah it is
it's really terrific in many many ways
and it's got relationships that are
worth taking a look at especially this
one between Ellie burr and her hero so I
would put it on the list just don't view
it when you're depressed okay Albert of
course in hitch Oda Mae brown in ghost
remember how wonderfully charming that
relationship was she becomes the medium
through which the dead guy can speak to
his living girlfriend they weren't
married were they I don't I don't think
so I think was a girlfriend and she's
perfect and she's hilarious
and Peter brand and so forth okay I have
picked also here an opposite-sex a
sidekick
I want you to see how this works too
this is not the obvious one of the
obvious ones okay and this is out of
Inception and it's Ariadne remember he
Cobb I'm assuming most
you have seen this picture yes has
anybody not seen it just okay mm-hmm
okay
put it on the list he has taken he's
putting together a team because he needs
to enter a CEOs dreams and fool him into
changing his mind about something
extremely important it's rather
intellectual but physically it works
visually it works very very well in the
movies extraordinary movie actually and
she is the architect he has hired and
brought in so she goes back she's
curious about her hero here because he's
acting kind of funny kind of strange he
can tell that there's something going on
inside of him that she really thinks she
needs to know about finds Cobb hooked to
the dream machine and she joins him she
hooks herself up to the same dream their
upcoming job is dangerous so she needs
to know more about Cobbs
troubled dreams what is he hiding and
then she finds herself wakes up in the
dream and finds herself descending in
this decrepit wonderful old elevator
descending into Cobbs dark psyche and
she finds him in a room of a house
somewhere speaking and low low tones low
personal tones with a woman she doesn't
yet know that this is mall and that this
is this is his dead wife all is dead and
the only place she still exists is in
Cobbs memory and dreams and but all of a
sudden there's a there's another person
in the dream so mall and Cobb are
startled that they're with somebody and
they see they're not alone Cobb runs
over you know he's got to get her out of
there as quickly as he can I'll get
Ariadne out of there he says what are
you doing here this has nothing to do
with you
and she retorts like a good sidekick
would it has everything to do with me
you've asked me to share
with you I need to go implication I need
to know what the heck is going on in
here well I guess I jumped the gun I
need to know what's going on with you
yes there are things you should know
he's not always you know antagonistic
towards his sidekick that is not the
nature of the hero sidekick relationship
he knows he's he's got a show or
something and let her in on something so
Cobb takes her deeper into his dream
world he is willing to reveal parts of
his troubled psyche to his sidekick he
takes her to his home at another time
and he shows her his home takes her down
the hall and into his home and shows him
her to his two children that he longs
more than anything to return to that's
his goal actually but the children never
quite turned to me I can never see their
faces he confesses he's always denied
fulfillment of being with them and
holding them and having them see him too
and re-add me says these aren't dreams
they're memories and you told me never
to use memories see she's on this stuff
she's learning she's putting two and two
together
Ariadne slips back into the
elevator without Cobb and pushes the
basement button she must find out what
haunts Cobb the most so at the very
bottom in the basement of things that he
protects about himself she finds his
darkest memory is about a hotel suite
where furniture has been trashed and
thrown thrown around like it'd been a
big fight or something like that and
then she noticed over on the on the
couch is the same woman that she saw
before
this is mall this is Cobbs dead wife
remembered in his memories and dreams
mall hisses you don't belong here the
sidekick finds herself trying to
understand the nature of the heroes
do you know what it is to be a lover to
be half of a whole and and Ariadne is
just kind of overwhelmed by at all it
just no and what she does not see it at
least it's shot in a way that she does
not see that mall leans over basically
and picks up a weapon a broken a broken
wineglass Cobb arrives pulls Ariadne
back into the elevator just in time
because Maul attacks her Maul attacks
and screams you promised you promised
and she's talking to Cobb obviously he
has promised her something
Ariadne now understands that Maul could
show up in their dream at any time with
the power to kill people she insists the
other members of the team need to be
told
okay I've had to skip over a whole lot
of stuff but what she is doing the
absorption of information about her hero
how she pushes back on her hero as he
tries to cover things up forcing him to
deal with the troubling stuff inside
this is classic this is classic sidekick
stuff and there is no no hint of
anything romantic between the two of
them that would that would ruin the
whole sidekick thing that's not an issue
here that would that would change the
dynamic and it just wouldn't work in
this case the sidekick not as skilled as
the hero that is true here remains
completely loyal that is absolutely true
of her does not die actually that is
true also in it by the end provides
counsel and conflict for the hero
exactly what she does
usually same sex but not always and can
echo a hero's romance with a comedic one
of her own in that case that is
irrelevant but that is how she fits into
that category okay mentor
I just two more two more hang in and
these are gonna go relatively quickly
but I would like you to see tonight at
least these six the mentor can be any
person any age as long as they pass on
skills and wisdom to the hero they can
there can be more than one mentor in a
story like Star Wars there are several
mentors going on there the mentor often
dies but not always the mentor gives a
hero a life-saving gift and that is
almost always that's what happens
whether it's knowledge or it's an actual
gift or if it's you know teaching the
hero about the power of the force that
is a life-saving gift that obi-wan
passes on they can be also dishonest in
morale or a reprobate that has nothing
to do with what we're going to be seeing
now here but like for instance what a
league of their own
you know the Tom Hanks part of the
drunken guy who gets the job of being
their coach a reprobate and turns into
quite a meaningful and powerful mentor
character can be dishonest or immoral or
a reprobate and can be negative this one
gets overlooked sometimes can be
negative and be teaching or trying to
teach the hero the wrong way to live in
the firm met remember that Tom Cruise
film the Gene Hackman character I forget
the character's name but he's assigned
you know then he's the new the new be
the Tom Cruise character he is a son
he's the partner of the firm who's
assigned to teach him the glories of the
ways of working in a firm that their
major client is the Mafia and he shows
him in a very sad way because he was at
one time a very decent man and how this
how working for this firm had but he
doesn't even know this is what he was
showing him but how it has sucked the
soul out of the guy he's crushed by what
he has done with his life okay some
successful mentors I'm going to show you
the matrix I got a bit on the matrix
here Morpheus is you know the classic
father figure of all time Penny Lane
also interesting as I mean she is a
young woman groupie in almost famous and
she is teaching the hero
what is 16 year old I think sport a
music writer
how do you know groupie world you know
how to be a groupie and following and
following a band and basically she's a
negative mentor teaching him how hollow
this life really is Matilda and Leon the
professional how many have seen that one
yeah runs late night you know they play
it all the time it's really a terrific
movie if you get a chance to see it I
mean you don't have to go out of your
way but if you get a chance to see it
see it because in this case the mentor
is a 12 year old girl and because her
mother and father are killed by the bad
crazed bad guy and she takes up with and
follows and and and seeks for protection
Leon who is himself a hitman for
protection but what she ends up doing is
giving Leon a reason to live teaching
him about life yes it was one of her
first one of her very first films and
it's I think a very powerful film anyway
Simon and as good as it gets and Chaz
Reinhold in wedding crashers if anybody
remembers that one again he's a negative
he's a negative mentor there and even in
The Wizard of Oz okay okay I will assume
most of you have seen the matrix
Trinity this in in jirobo this is the
end of hero gol sequence v and Trinity
has taken neo up in this strange
building to meet Morpheus for the first
time and he's been built up as as quite
something and it's important to meet him
and it's an honor to meet him so she
says and he asked her I think is there
anything I should know
and she says be honest he knows more
than you can imagine
so knock knock and they go in over by
the window waiting is Morpheus and the
first thing he says is at last neo says
it's an honor to meet you and Morpheus
says no the honor is all mine
this mentor is already giving his gift
right upfront his gift to the hero and
it is the gift of knowing that he is
special and that he is chosen by their
mythology by the rebel mythology and all
he has to do is come to believe it
himself and that's his arc his growth
art I imagine you're feeling a bit like
Alice tumbling down the rabbit hole all
the images all those images are coming
into play here even Alice Through the
Looking Glass that's going to get used
here in a minute - you're here because
you oh yes listen you're here because
you know something you can't put your
finger on it but you've always known
that something was wrong and the reason
I'm particularly pointing out this
passage is that is the state the
emotional state of almost all heroes in
the first act they are living in their
own world their own in their life
yesterday the world they've always lived
in and it's just day to day and you know
okay it's there and they do it but they
know that something is wrong it hasn't
been even maybe hasn't even been
articulated yet but something is wrong
with society
and what they don't know is they are the
one who is going to set it right
Morpheus says you were born into a
prison you cannot taste or smell or
touch a prison for your mind can you
imagine when this first came out and was
speaking to young people teens and young
people all over the world how they're
just sitting there nodding and saying
yes yes that's me that's how I feel
the identification here was complete
with an entire generation you cannot be
told what the matrix is you must see it
for yourself all I'm offering is the
truth and then the classic moment when
Morpheus offered the two pills picked
blue or pick red blue you wake up in
your bed then you go on about your lives
and you forgot this all together pick
the red and there's no turning back so
of course the hero picks the red and
that is the inciting incident when he
chooses and swallows the red pill that
is what begins this story and no other
he is defined by that act and there's no
going back that has already been stated
through him so that is the end of Hira
goal sequence 5 and it pushes us in the
hero goal sequence 6 and cipher Amit's
you meet some some of the crew cipher
says buckle your seat belt Dorothy
because Kansas is going bye-bye
and things start to get weird and change
and the mirror starts to flow and he
touches it if you'll recall and then the
mirror latches on to his finger and
starts pouring up his arm and there's no
stopping it
and it's about to drown him not looking
good for ya but then this this takes him
boom he wakes up in a you know in a tank
like thing
and covered by membrane and tubes and he
fights his way out right it's like being
born it's a metaphor it's being reborn
into the real world he fights he gets up
and he takes a look outside of his own
pod to see millions and millions of
other pods just like it you've been
living in a dream world neo this is the
world as it is today watch this what do
we call that look bingo
stunning surprise one for neo he wakes
up and he sees the real world for the
first time eyes open wide mouth open
drippy with birthing goo yeah it takes
place 33 minutes in which is just about
perfect and welcome to act 2 neo he is
thrown into this new world in which his
entire adventure and story will take
place welcome to the desert of the real
we've done it Trinity we found him again
a reiteration of the fact that the the
mentor is utterly convinced that this is
the chosen one who is worthy of all the
instruction that now must be given ok
mentor can be any person of any age yes
can be more than one mentor in a story
in this case actually there's only one
mentor the mentor often dies but not
always in this case he almost dies he's
captured and he's tortured but he does
not die and I think there's a very good
storytelling reason for that I won't go
into it now but somebody remind me later
and we may have a discussion about why
the mentor is actually allowed to live
here in this story gives whoops did
gives a hero a life-saving gift yes
belief that he is extraordinarily
special can be dishonest not irrelevant
here can be negative not relevant here
okay one last one the endangered
innocent the endangered innocent as I
was pointing out earlier I was talking
about the wives of the astronauts they
were they that's their function they're
endangered innocents they are the story
goal they are the ones that need to be
saved and that is the story goal too in
they are in imminent danger of death or
loss and the stakes have to be nothing
less than that as high as stakes can be
for whatever story you're telling and
can be one person or a group
yes provides a strong subplot an
enormous ly strong subplot must be
sympathetic what must be sympathetic
they are provides a ticking clock and a
ticking clock we will come and refer to
again and again that is really important
they usually start at the midpoint the
ticking clock but it means time is
running out to accomplish whatever it is
the hero is out to accomplish
the ticking clock zero hour is
approaching get on it and make it happen
okay my example for you here is Kevin
the bird in up he is the endangered
innocent Carl and his friends have
escaped from evil adversary Charles
Muntz is cave and and his nasty dogs who
are his adversary agents and now they
continue pulling Ellie's and Carl's
house this last short distance to
Paradise Falls he's almost there is
almost an accomplished his task Kevin
when their escape from you know the
previous escape kevin has been wounded
kevin was was basic to their escaping at
all and and was wounded
so she's bandaged and resting on the
steps
Russell tells Carl about the happy times
he had with his dad but they were but
they're foreign to few those those happy
times and the boy is clearly needing a
father figure and he's Russell more and
more with their adventures together he
tried to dismiss him in the beginning
but more and more Carl is falling for
Russell and seeing Carl's immediate
today needs as weighed against the needs
of his past and being caught in the past
and all of a sudden there's a car in the
distance a high-pitched car and Kevin
jumps up and it is her babies it is one
of her babies they have found the nest
and Kevin is jubilant and runs off and
Russell and Carl also so excited that
I'm gonna be able to get Kevin home and
as they run over joyed an ominous shadow
comes over them that they don't see
right away of spotlight a very hot
blinding spotlight suddenly turns on and
nails Kevin the bird who freezes in it
the evil adventurer months is huge blimp
hovers above and he's come for Kevin a
live version of That Bird he's got a
skeleton in you know it is if you
remember in this museum in his blimp
they're all dead things and skeletons
and he always wanted to find a live one
and here's a live one and he's going to
get it in the hovers above and he has
come for Kevin a net thing made of thick
ropes shoots out and and traps Kevin so
Kevin can't move and Carl works very
very fast to cut him free get him out of
there as quickly as possible action
sequence and in the meantime you know
the off ramp lowers from the blimp and
down comes the evil adventurer months
and his sinister pack of adversary agent
dogs I keep repeating that because that
is it whether they are dogs or people
they are serving the will
the other of the adversary and in these
he's made them you know it's a it's a
cartoon it's it's animation and these
these dogs are given the power of speech
so they speak think and behave
personified like people but he has a
lantern and to draw Carl away from Kevin
the bird the cruel adventure adventurer
throws the lantern under Ellie's house
to set it on fire this is was a very
startling you know to go this far as I
recall was a very startling thing to see
whether you are adult or a child at the
time the first time you saw it very
cruel and of course in an instant
Carl does not wrestle he cannot wrestle
with this decision he's got to save
Ellie's house it is it is the mausoleum
of all his precious memories and life
with Ellie so he runs to try to save the
house while the dogs run up to Holloway
Kevin the hero pose Ellie's house aloft
it's still just floating you know a few
feet off the ground because the the
balloons are getting tired and losing
helium but he's able to pull it away and
get it away from the fire and he saves
the house but in the meantime months and
his vicious dogs dragged Kevin into the
bowels of the sinister blimp and poor
Russell he's devastated
carl has saved Elly's house but he has
given up Kevin the bird to a cruel fate
and he's obviously he's glad that he
saved the house but he's also feeling
like you know feeling really badly and
crushed Russell says to him you just
gave her away
you gave her away that's how the boy has
seen it because he doesn't understand
the pull you know within within Carl and
and and his experience and everything he
is lost when his wife died and the only
thing that really matters to the boy is
Kevin the bird and he snaps he gets
angry because of all of this emotion
being pressed down upon him I didn't ask
for any of this Doug the dog tries to
soothe Carl and Carl turns on him bad
dog bad dog okay and that's the end of
which hero goal sequence here I don't
quite remember the endangered innocent
is is the story goal actually actually
kevin has been the endangered innocent
in this film for a long time from about
the middle of the of the second act he
was set up to be the endangered innocent
it's been going on for a long time but
now you see a ticking clock has been
sent in motion save him quickly or it's
going to be too late in in a danger of
death or loss absolutely can be one
person or a group one person provides a
strong subplot you better believe it
must be sympathetic ah they come very
few come as sympathetic as Kevin is and
provides the ticking clock so you made
it there are in general between five and
seven main characters in an in movies in
movies that work
if you have as you must have a hero in
an adversary that means you will have
three to five more central characters in
order for your story to work I know
there are lots of students writing
scripts who don't have enough people who
don't have enough of a cast with knowing
exactly what their function is how they
are going to serve this story in one of
these categories but now you get to
choose what kind of story do you want
your story to be okay is a love interest
possible does that work that doesn't
work for all stories you know and you
don't want to push it a lot of people
wait on that a lot of people that it's
tricky to really make that work so okay
a sidekick or no sidekick we're gonna
talk about that a little later this
evening as a matter of fact after the
break but this is it when you know the
paradigm of how the blocks and pieces of
the puzzle fit together and now you've
got this you know what you're looking
for when you are looking to create
characters for your story these are the
character functions that are served by
these by these characters you may fight
it fine if you want to fight it for a
while that's fine by me
try it on I think the more you more
movies you go to the closer you look I
think the more you will see that I am
here to ruin the movies for you at least
for a short while just for a short while
you'll get over it
and you will be able to play that piano
like I was a virtuoso okay any any
immediate questions right now
yeah it's it's usually just one if you
have two people following and doing it's
not a sidekick anymore it's it's a
helper follower to help or follower
characters category from that category
then it's like well like you know uh
Ocean's eleven that hero Danny ocean he
gets a true sidekick who sticks with him
all the time and he's also got all these
helper followers going to so he's got
the whole ball of wax because some plots
require that to rob a casino takes a lot
of people and a lot of different skills
but anything else for now in up Kevin
the bird was is the first of the strange
friends picked up by by Russell he goes
to you know because to do number two and
the bin bushes and he takes he digs the
hole and does all the things they taught
him in camp or school but this huge bird
comes up and eats his candy bar is
chocolate I think he's got or something
like that and and then there's some
comedy and romping with with with Carl
and all that stuff but the thing is
immediately after that Doug the dog
shows up and the first thing Doug the
dog says is my master wants me to bring
a bird home I'm going to take this bird
prisoner can I take your bird prisoner
in other words Doug the dog is just the
sweetheart and doesn't know about being
mean but he is telling us from the first
time he arrives which is very shortly
after the time that kevin has arrived
somebody is out to get Kevin and he's
the master my master this and my master
that can I take him home and be a hero
so that is what I mean by its laid in
its laid in early and then during the
midpoint sequence and they're having
dinner with with with months
and there he's just a Karl is just
catching up to the this is not good you
know this is a creepy guy and a creepy
place although he was friendly and they
in the beginning they thought okay we
got a new friend but he sees outside the
portholes he sees Kevin bouncing around
having fun and doing things and then oh
my gosh you know if months sees that
Kevin is gone he's lost right then and
there
so again Kevin is at risk and that is
one of the main reasons that they grab
and run they grab Kevin and run and try
to get him out of there and then it goes
on and on and you remember huh what act
what act three is stunning surprise to
of up
anybody remember not quite not quite
stunning surprise to of up is when is
when Carl goes outside and Russell has
gotten a few balloons and tied him
around himself and he's got this leaf
blower or something and he's in the air
and his I'm gonna go save Kevin what out
of the blue changes everything here his
life is never gonna be the same again
and then then what does Carl do by then
he has completed his character growth
arc and he gets it the stuff in his
house yes it has sentimental meaning to
him but it's just stuff and he starts
throwing it out in order to lighten the
house so that he can get it back up into
the air again
and go save Russell and Kevin which
which he does he takes it's the the
metaphor is so perfect and so complete
all the stuff he has in that house that
means so much to him the furniture that
he throws it all away to make it into a
flying machine you get yet again to get
it in the air and go after and be the
hero who's going to save Russell and
Kevin and metaphorically he has finally
left the past behind and he has
committed
to a future and then that's in the knack
three is this kind of very lovely and
elongated obligatory scene
anything else for now thank you for your
patience
I know this this this was a long one
longer one but there's a lot of juice
here guys there's a lot of things to
think about and to see how all of this
fits together and it's it's really
critical to what we're going to be doing
and what you're going to be doing
starting next semester at least with me
writing a feature film okay take a break
Thanks